bonjour l'iphone 10 a eu un vrai succès
il ya eu plein d'infos plein de rumeurs
certains prédisent effectivement la fin
de l' iphone 10 une info dont je vous
avais déjà parlé il ya quelques temps il
ya eu des démentis on savait pas trop
aux filières qui en étaient esprit
phonie c'était un vrai succès commercial
est-ce que l'iphone disent plutôt un
bide est ce que l'iphone dit sa lettre
avorté oui nous en fin de compte pas du
tout apple a fait un de ses meilleurs
trimestre n'ont jamais fait des chiffres
de die
on va en parler maintenant
vichy freddy forcément pris de notes
puisque les chiffres appris par coeur
vous allez voir c'est super intéressant
parce que les résultats financiers sont
excellents pour apple
ils ont fait 61 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
une augmenter l'âge ne parle que d'un
trimestre encore attention je ne parle
pas de l'année je ne parle que du
dernier trimestre 61 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires une augmentation de
16% un bénéfice de 2,73 dollars par
action une augmentation de 30% c'est
complètement magne c'est vraiment un
truc qui est complètement fou la vente
des iphone a augmenté de 3%
il ya en tout 50 2,2 millions d'iphone
qui ont été vendus ce trimestre ça
représente 62% du chiffre d'affaires
total d'apple
autant vous dire que à peu ce sont les
iphone ça serait pas tout à fait la même
boîte quand même alors on va pas se
mentir l'iphone 10 pour le coup est un
vrai succès commercial c'est un produit
qui marche très très bien et qui arrive
vraiment à capter les gens qui veulent
des produits des smartphones très haut
de gamme
tim cook je le cite nos clients ont
choisi l'iphone 10 plus qu'aucun autre
iphone chaque semaine de ce trimestre
exactement comme ils l'ont fait depuis
son lancement en décembre
l'iphone dit c'est donc un vrai succès
commercial qui garantie apple des
revenus toujours plus haut des bénéfices
toujours plus haut les actionnaires
toujours plus heureux alors les autres
produits maintenant les ipad se vendent
plutôt pas mal
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un bon resto du
côté des ipad du côté des max sait moins
c'est effectivement les mac c'est pas
les meilleures ventes c'est plutôt en
dégringolade sa abc avoir effectivement
ce qui va arriver aux dames a lieu
d'habitude ici où on attend de nouveaux
mac macbook macbook air probablement
macbook pro en espérant que ça va
booster un peu les ventres en espérant
pour eux c'est pas forcément moi j'ai
pas d'action sharepoint complètement
après on va pas se mentir et les
services son concours vraiment en rose
les services de musique et les services
de vidéo
il y aussi un quelque chose qui
fonctionne plutôt bien c'est l'apple
watch et l'apple tv qui cartonne
vraiment alors la répartition du chiffre
d'affaires est assez intéressante parce
qu'on voit que 41 % du chiffre
d'affaires d'apple est réalisé en
amérique 23% en europe 21 % en chine et
9 % au japon donc on va très bien que
aujourd'hui apple fait quasiment
quasiment la moitié son chiffre
d'affaires en amérique amériques s'est
pas uniquement états unis c'est vraiment
tous continents confondus
la chine est aussi très très gros avec
21% il faut savoir que la chine c'est
quasiment le chiffre d'affaires de
l'europe ont dites vous bien que sur un
seul et même pays la chine sa
concurrence réellement l'europe
d'où l'intérêt pour apple de réussir sur
le marché chinois est justement apple
s'est mis en tête de racheter les
actions des racheter des actions de
leurs actionnaires effectivement pour
devenir encore plus propriétaires de
leurs boîtes et gagner encore plus
d'argent in fine et de pouvoir encore
plus s'investir et de faire encore plus
de shaun hill devrait racheter jusqu'à
100 milliards de dollars d'actions c'est
vraiment des chiffres complètement
dingos là on parle de 60 1 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires sur un trimestre
imaginons à la fin de la guerre que ça
donnait ça va être complètement ouf
autant dire que l'iphone 10 a de beaux
jours devant lui qu'apple ne s'est pas
du tout planté en créant cet iphone
comme ils l'ont fait l'encoche marché on
comprend mieux pourquoi tout le monde
maintenant il va de bon coeur derrière
au final on peut dire que cet iphone 10
est un produit d'avenir on attend
effectivement partir du mois de
septembre
trois nouveaux iphone avec le même
design la même encoches donc autant vous
dire que l'encoche on va la voir on va
la garder et elle va durer encore un bon
moment
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous vous êtes surpris des
chiffres d'apple est ce que vous pensiez
qu'effectivement apple souffrais
beaucoup de talent fundis est ce que
vous pensez qu effectivement c'est un
produit beaucoup trop cher qu'il ne
pouvait pas marcher
est ce qu'au contraire vous comprenez
vite on en attendait c'est normal parce
que des iphone on en voit partout des
iphone 10 on en voit de partout quand on
se déplace que ce soit en france aux
états unis partout dans le monde on voit
énormément d'iphone dix mois pour ma
part j'ai voyagé il ya pas très
longtemps aux états unis si vous êtes
sur les iphone 10 des iphones j'en ai vu
partout donc ça ne surprend qu'à moitié
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire c'est aussi à laisser toutes
vos questions suggestions interrogations
tout ça directement en bas vous me
laissez des jolies pouces vous vous
abonnez vous allez voir on va parler
toujours plus de teck de produits et
technologies innovants et croyez moi
croyez moi sur parole il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent et beaucoup de
surprises à partir du 20 septembre
donc d'ici là soyez ça je vous embrasse
peu de rendez vous très très très
bientôt
pour les soirées vous donc à très
bientôt st
[Musique]